under constant Russian attack there are
fewer and fewer safe passageways into
and out of bakmut a city in Ukraine's
Eastern Donetsk region where fewer than
5 000 people remain we wanted to stay
but how can we this resident says it's
time for us to go while Ukraine has
stabilized the front line how long it
can hold it in place is unknown
it's on fire this Soldier says but
Ukraine will live
buckmut has been a target for months
weakened it's now almost entirely
encircled according to the leader of
Russia's mercenary Wagner group Moscow
sees this city as a doorway to The
donbass Experts argue the town is small
and simply an obsession for Russia's
president and while securing it has come
at a steep price Victory could too it
will be a tactical victory for Putin but
it will be a strategic defeat because
he's
chewed up so many units trying to take
bakmut Russia's confidence is getting a
slight boost its defense minister even
making a rare trip into what it calls
russian-controlled Ukraine awarding
medals to his soldiers
good luck success and come home alive he
told them before meeting with military
leaders where more weapons and training
were discussed
the trip comes just one day after the
U.S announced another 400 million
dollars in crucial Aid these
contributions are making a significant
difference enabling Ukraine to defend
its sovereignty for Ukraine its future
remains on the line but for Russia it
comes down to the future of one man he's
a dictator who has cast the dice in a
failing military effort and he feels
it's necessary to have what he can be
sold as a victory in order to prevent
some kind of social explosion at home
and while Ukraine says it won't withdraw
from bakmut It's Quickly running out of
time and resources
Reggie Global News Washington